hey I want to ask you about Harley Quinn
let's talk about Harley Quinn for a
second yeah this is an animated series
and I love that you're occasionally you
just hear a dog objection one of my
question it's like it's your publicist
we're not talking about Harley Quinn I'm
like being trapped in like a very narrow
animated character Harley Quinn is as
crazy as she is she's very relatable
that's what I honestly love about the
show I mean there'll be scenes where
Harley is literally out slashing
someone's throat while she's texting her
she or she'll be like killing someone
and she's like ah I need a latte like
yeah very relatable and weirdly grounded
and I can't believe some of the stuff
were allowed to say I don't even know if
we're lab but we do it and they've let
us do it so I'm hope I hope we do
another season if people seem to really
like it there's this rumor relationships
possible relationship between Harley
Quinn and poison ivy and I just want to
say I'm all for that let me let me put
it this way Harley's gonna need some
calamine lotion okay that was the funny
joke I just thought of that off the top
of my head the calamine the poison ivy
get it oh yeah I'm writing that down
I've never found anything I've said in
the last 10 years that I'm using that I
go hold on
thank you make sure I get the word out
on that season 2 of Harley Quinn is now
streaming on DC Universe yes and new
episodes are available every Friday and
also I want to mention this look out for
the flight attendant coming soon to HBO
max anything about it
I want to say we have a few more
episodes left we're still hoping to get
it out this year but you know we're kind
of in the same boat as everybody else so
right it's it's you know it's it's so
frustrating I just want all that crew
all the crews to go back to work us get
back in there but who knows when that's
gonna happen I don't know we're gonna
get there we're gonna get there in the
meantime I'm happy to come by and help
Carl with the pumpkin social distance
six feet Carl
six feet from the bumpkin okay okay I'm
excited to look up some eggplant
pollination as well now that you
mentioned it yeah that's not really
interesting no I'm very big into the
world of vegan porn sure you go ahead
yeah that's fine
hey Kaylee thank you so much for talking
to me no you really did lift my spirits
you're a very I always love talking to
you you're very buoyant fun cool person
to talk to
I mean you are absolutely awesome I love
talking your show you make it so easy
and I really look forward to seeing you
so thank you for having me all right and
I look forward to seeing you at the
supermarket dressed like Scrooge you all
build which is which is Noble which is
no guys fantasy by the way it's not
really thank you very much this is great
and we'll see you later bye